okay so this video is going to be on
organic molecules carbon-based molecules
so let's go ahead and get started so as
I said a moment ago organic molecules
are carbon-based so carbon is the
building block of organic molecules and
there's four categories of organic
molecules carbohydrates you know fruits
are high in carbohydrates lipids you
know the cell membrane is a phospholipid
bilayer and it's it's made from a double
layer of lipids you know eggs eggs are
high in proteins proteins are a category
of organic molecule and then nucleic
acids such as DNA so these are the four
categories of organic molecules now I
have a separate video on each of them if
you want to go over the basic features
of each this video however is going to
mainly focus on carbon so when we look
at carbon or carbon is unique and you
know before I go over why carbon is
unique let's look at the square from the
periodic table I see the atomic number
six means it has six protons and that
also means it's got six electrons now
the twelve does not mean it has 12
neutrons it's got six neutrons because
the twelve the atomic mass is when you
add up the protons plus the neutrons so
six protons Plus what mystery number
equals 12 well that would be six well in
the nucleus of atoms you find the
protons and the neutrons therefore the
electrons are orbiting in these levels
these electron levels and you might know
the first electron level can carry two
electrons
after that it's considered filled and
stable that means carbons four remaining
electrons must be in the second electron
level so notice how the first electron
level is filled completely filled with
two electrons we call it stable but the
second electron levels not filled it's
unstable it only has four electrons but
eight are required to make the second
electron level stable so this is why
carbon is unique it will bond up to four
times and by doing so
it makes these rather large complex
organic molecules so carbon is going to
actually fit carbon figure out a way to
obtain a fifth sixth a seventh and an
eighth eighth electron from other atoms
in order to become stable and this
explains why there's such a wide array
of organic carbon-based molecules now
when we talk about organic molecules we
want to talk about their monomers the
monomers are the building blocks
monomers are small or small carbon-based
organic molecules now ultimately you
might know there are four categories of
organic molecules there are proteins and
there are nucleic acids and there are
carbohydrates and there are lipids and
each of these are made from small
building blocks called monomers so
here's a small building block here's a
monomer and when a bunch of monomers
join and bond together they make a
larger chain called a polymer polymers
are larger chains of monomers polymers
are complex carbon-based molecules now
we're going to go over each of them each
of the four kinds in just a moment so
when we look at monomers first of all
proteins the category called proteins
are made from building blocks small
monomers called amino acids so there's
an amino acid and when a bunch of amino
acids timed together these amino acids
form what's called a polypeptide and
that's the polymer of a protein
now the polypeptide will twist and fold
into a final final protein and that is
all discussed in my separate video
specifically related to proteins
now there's another category called
nucleic acids
well nucleic acids are made from a
building block called a nucleotide so
here's a nucleotide and what a bunch of
nucleotides bind together these this
long chain of nucleotides makes up the
polymer called a nucleic acid
well here's another monomer called a
monosaccharide you know monosaccharides
saccharide simply means sugar in mono
means one so here's one sugar
but when a monosaccharide burns with a
bunch of other monosaccharides it
creates a polysaccharide and these are
the monomers and polymers of
carbohydrates
now lipids are a little more tricky
because there's actually two monomers
lipids are made from a long-chain called
a fatty acid and then a molecule called
glycerol and when a glycerol barns with
several fatty acids this makes up a
lipid now again I have videos on each of
these but I hope you see the point that
organic molecules are made from small
building blocks called monomers and
those monomers are built up into
polymers and what all of these have in
common is they're all built around
carbon because they are after all
organic now I want to show you you know
how these atoms kind of bond together
using a pretty simple example methane
ch4 methane is made from carbon and
hydrogen so click on the left in blue is
carbon stable I hope you see no it's not
stable as we said earlier it only has
four electrons in the second level it
needs four more how about in red
hydrogen on the right is hydrogen stable
with its one electron in the first level
no it needs one more electron to become
stable because two electrons are what
fills up that first electron level so
what atoms do when they are unstable
well they bond to form molecules so
let's look at methane methane is ch4 so
there's actually one two three four
hydrogens that will bond to this carbon
in order to form this molecule called
methane and if we focus on the top
hydrogen notice how the electrons
overlap and are shared this is an
example of a covalent bond so the one
electron in red that hides in
normally possesses and by borrowing the
electron in blue the hydrogen on top has
become stable it's it's obtained two
electrons same with the hydrogen on the
right it has its own electron in red and
it's borrowing an electron in blue from
carbon so the hydrogen on the right is
also stable same with the hydrogen at
the bottom it has its own electron in
red and it's sharing and borrowing a
blue electron from carbon it too is
stable and of course the same thing goes
for the hydrogen on the Left it has its
own electron in red and it's sharing a
blue electron from carbon it too is
stable now what about that carve the
blue carbon in the middle the blue
carbon in the middle is also stable
because it has its four electrons in the
second level in blue and it's also
borrowing the electrons from hydrogen
and so it is figured out a way to obtain
and to fill its electron levels and
become stable this is a great example of
a covalent covalent a molecule that is
connected by covalent bonds now there's
a little bit of a problem when it comes
to drawing these dot diagrams you know
the dots representing the electrons
they're little time consuming so you
will very often see this done instead
notice how the dashes are representing
the bonds between the carbon and the
hydrogen so notice that one dash is
equivalent to two electrons here's
another one notice how one dash is
equivalent to two electrons so these
dash diagrams are just simpler and
easier to read and they're just less
time-consuming to draw and again here's
another example here's a molecule cf4
you could take the time to do all the
dots draw all the dots if you like or
you could simply do this again notice
that every single dash represents two
electrons
and so because carbon can bind up to
four times very complex molecules can be
created now here's methane again and
notice how you have all single dashes
these are called single bonds so if we
focus on the carbon notice how there are
four dashes associated with the carbon
in the middle
well one dash is equivalent to two
electrons so four dashes would be eight
electrons notice how that carbon in the
middle is stable here's a more complex
carbon-based molecules you see let's
just pick one
let's pick that carbon right there
notice how there are four dashes coming
off of that carbon while four dashes
represents eight electrons notice how
that carbon and all the other carbons
are stable what about this you see these
double dashes almost looks like an equal
sign or these are called double bonds
these are sharing two sets of electrons
so pick any carbon of those four let's
pick the one on the far right notice how
there are four dashes attached to the
carbon on the right one dash equals two
electrons so four dash is equals eight
electrons this carbon and all the other
carbons are stable well here's a triple
bond three dashes is what we call a
triple bond these are very very strong
bonds and pick a carbon either the one
on the left and one on the right let's
take the one on the left notice how
there are four dashes attached to the
carbon on the left that equals eight
electrons the carbon is stable and a
carbon will also form these ring
structures and again you can pick any
carbon out of this chain here any carbon
out of the ring excuse me let's pick
that carbon right there notice how that
carbon has four dashes attached to it
four dashes equals eight electrons that
carbon and all the others are stable
so there you go there's a quick
introduction to carbon and organic based
molecules again I have a separate video
on proteins and lipids and amino acids
and carbohydrates but that will
hopefully get you started you know leave
your comments in the box below and I
hope you found this helpful
thanks for watching